hey 42 here in 1998 a tennessee high
school teacher declared to her students
that she smelt something like gasoline
within minutes she was feeling nauseous
short of breath and suffering from a
headache soon after and many students in
her class began to feel the same
symptoms and almost like a pandemic the
entire school was soon struck down with
the same strange set of symptoms but
what was going on the building was
evacuated and emergency services called
in to deal with the sick students and
staff and that investigation was
undertaken with over seventy eight
individuals admitted to the emergency
room and thirty-eight hospitalized this
was a mystery that had to be solved
however that would be easier said than
done
all the blood tests came back clean
investigations into the building found
nothing and every single person admitted
to hospital survived so what the hell
happened
the answer was fear writing in the New
England Journal of Medicine
epidemiologist dr. Timothy F Jones
described the incident as a mass
psychogenic illness where the teacher
the students and eventually the whole
school were infected by a fear of a
toxic substance they believed was there
but it wasn't and their fear was so
palpable it manifested physical symptoms
and spread from one individual to the
next until it had taken down the entire
school
it turns out that that fear like
laughter the flu and chlamydia is
incredibly contagious but why and how
does it work the merriam-webster
dictionary defines fear as an unpleasant
often strong emotion caused by
anticipation or awareness of danger
it's a gripping horrible feeling that
seizes the entire body and your brain
begs you to flee from harm just like
when you see an attractive woman we all
know what fear feels like we've been
feeling it our entire lives and we all
want to be free of it but as you will
soon learn a it's not possible and B if
you could erase fear from your life it
would actually be a terrible idea the
story of the fearless warrior who
confronts the unknown is the most
ancient we have the oldest known stories
mesopotamias Gilgamesh slaying monsters
and seeking to cheats death the oldest
known story in English is the guyot's
Beowulf ripping Grendel's arm off
hunting his mother down in a cave and
slayed a dragon and even the modern
comic book story of the Batman has the
hero draping himself in his worst fear
in order to weaponize it fear and
mastery of it has been a permanent
mainstay in human culture it is one of
our oldest most persistent enemies and
we all carry it with us in some way
every single day
there are thousands upon thousands of
phobias and humanity has an inexplicable
predilection towards giving them all
Greek names from the ridiculous elector
phobia the fear of chickens to the very
real and almost universally terrifying
philosopher BIA which is the fear of
deep water and the ungodly or knowable
evil that lurks within it but there is a
reason why there are so many phobias and
why some of them are so absurd studies
have shown that human beings can teach
themselves or be taught to be afraid of
just about
one not so ethical study called the
little Albert experiment saw a child
conditioned by scientists to fear
anything fluffy the method for doing
this was terrifying the poor child every
time he touched a fluffy rat the result
he started to his pants at the
sight of anything fluffy despite having
no notion of it beforehand this is
likely why so many people who have a bud
encounter of a dog early in life Harbor
such terror towards them later although
admittedly the little Albert experiment
was so widely immoral bizarre and on
rigorous that it would struggle to hold
up to modern scientific scrutiny yet the
staggering variety of phobias does lend
some credence to its original point
however whilst there are many fears it
is worth noting that certain fears such
as a fear of meteors getting kidnapped
or fairies generally decline with age
perhaps due to the fact that we go
through life realizing that these events
rarely if ever happen although you
should probably stay on your guard for a
fairy kidnapping being halted by a
meteor strike because you just never
know the experience of fear involves a
substantial portion of your brains
functional capacity chief amongst ease
is your amygdala a little section of the
brain that rests just behind your Ryan
across from each year but although these
two almond-shaped nuclei clusters are
small they are exceptionally powerful
they are almost entirely responsible for
your brains alarm system constantly
scanning for threats and signaling the
body to respond and although they do
have of a function such as triggering
regression and anxiety their fear
response is perhaps the most palpable
and in many ways beneficial as it is
likely our amygdalas itchy trigger
finger that got us safely for a time
when our world was ridden with homo
Farion latter dooms
in short without the amygdala you and
humanity itself who wouldn't have much
of a future but the brain itself is
incredibly complex and it responds to
fear involves more than just e amygdala
in
fact the brain is composed of around 100
billion nerve cells with 100 trillion
communicating connections that help us
to think sense eat sleep and find porn
on the internet
whilst many of these communications are
conscious such as turning left or right
in a car of a communications produce
what is known as an autonomic response
these unconscious processes include the
functioning of vital organs such as the
heart and lungs but fear is also one of
these autonomic responses we don't
choose to feel afraid we simply feel
afraid and we have next to no control
over how long it lasts or how intense it
feels so for those of you trying to will
your way out of being afraid
good luck there are about 4.5 4 billion
years of evolution working against you
alongside the amygdalas perma scanning
the alarm system there are other
elements of the brain that play a role
in fear the brainstem makes us freeze
the hippocampus activates our
fight-or-flight response the
hypothalamus gets our adrenals firing
hormones into our system the prefrontal
cortex helps us figure out what the hell
is going on by interpreting what's
happening and comparing it to the past
and the thalamus not to be confused with
the FAL more who are the some
Skyrim receives raw data from our
various senses and sends processed
information to either the sensory cortex
where we have more conscious control or
the amygdala where it's pretty much a
dice roll as to whether we our
pants or not so I guess it is actually a
bit of an as well if the cortex
is our thinking brain and the amygdala
hypothalamus and hippocampus which help
compose the limbic system are our
emotional brain and this is despite
Qasimi between conscious thinking
decisions and unconscious emotional
reactions which makes fear such a
difficult experience to control the
experience if fear can be broken down
into three distinct components context
distraction and social learning
contacts plays a huge role in how we
experience fear and is why controlled
fear such as scary movies can be an
exhilarating experience instead of an
obsessing one when fear sends us into a
high arousal State our thinking brain
provides our emotional brain with
information as to what the context of
our fear is if we are safe then we can
quickly shift our experience of fear
into one of safe excitement such as the
terror felt of going over the edge of
the roller-coaster only to experience a
rush of excitement when we realize we're
safe secure and on a ride however if the
context is a 20-foot great white shark
tearing into our upper thigh with free
hundred razor-sharp teeth then the
context would be a fairly appropriate ah
I'm going to die now this ability to
shift one's perspective is helped by the
fact that although the fear response
begins in the amygdala it travels
various thinking and emotional brain
systems and your entire body to help you
rally an appropriate defense or flight
response although in truth what defense
is there whenever Aven is fifteen
hundred kilogram fish hits you at 35
miles per hour
the amygdala for instance reacts
whenever you see a human face if the
face is showing fear or aggression the
reaction will be more pronounced this
then leads your pupils to dilate the
brain to go into alert mode non vital
organs slow down more blood goes to your
skeletal muscles and your breathing
heightens this is what I unofficially
call Bassel mode like any animal we also
learn to fear things as we go through
life when we experience something
frightening it's a young age we carry
this experience with us for years to
come informing our choices and even our
personality an obvious example of this
is a fear of dogs but another more
abstract example would be abandonment if
you experience a fleeting moment of
abandonment as a child this fear can
stay with you your entire life informing
your behaviors in romantic relationships
but uniquely amongst humans is that we
can learn to fear
things from the written and spoken word
if we're about to swim at the beach and
someone screams shark will likely change
our mind like why is a large sign
warning us of snakes in the tall grass
will make us think twice about straying
from the path
in either case simply hearing or seeing
a warning can be enough to trigger our
body to go into alert battle mode state
lastly social learning has a huge impact
on what we learn to fear spending time
around dangerous animals that are docile
in the hands of trainers can drastically
alter our reaction to the same animal
such as a tame lion versitile one
although our initial reaction will be
one of fear and avoidance once we see
the animal is mostly harmless we will
begin to relax around it fear also
through the way it takes over our entire
body and flips it with hormones
distracts us and brings us into the here
and now for an animal played with
insecurities wandering attention and
addiction this can be a welcome plunge
into extreme clarity and focus this is
perhaps why alongside the addictive
nature of adrenaline people become so
addicted to experiencing fear in
controlled circumstances such as bungee
jumping or skydiving our perception
plays a large role in our relationship
with fear as with the example of the
timeline we can understand something if
our thinking brain assumes it to be safe
but if our emotional brain is
overwhelmed with fear we won't go
anywhere near it you see this all the
time of people afraid of deep water
although everyone knows the odds of a
shark attack are astronomically low many
people become deeply afraid as soon as
they can't see the bottom and will
rapidly swim for sure this is why there
are so many cliche horror films that
revolve around deep water they are
usually filled in such a way that
overwhelms the emotional brain so much
that the thinking brain's knowledge of
the movie's artificiality ceases to be a
factor in fact the emotional minds grip
on our experience of fear is so strong
that it can lead us to make completely
irrational decisions well beyond being
afraid of the statistically unlikely
people you have a strong fearful
reaction towards the
water don't just fear the sea and its
predators they also fear lakes and
swimming pools where their biggest enemy
would be a sturgeon or someone having a
piss even though there's zero
possibility of something terrible
lurking beneath the body can
inexplicably act as if there definitely
is and we can almost feel its presence
below us we even have similar reaction
from watching films like Paranormal
Activity or hereditary even though we're
relatively certain nuttin ghosts don't
exist
we'll find ourselves checking over our
shoulder as we head to bed afraid of an
eerie feeling that something
supernatural is behind us irrational or
not this isn't something our thinking
brain can actually control or fix fear
also has a market effect on our ability
to perceive time or more accurately if
you make time seem slower than it
actually is a study by the University of
New South Wales discovered that when
novice skydivers are preparing for a
jump they perceived the preparation time
to be far longer than it actually is
because their body is hopped up on a
chemical soup of hormones and has been
put into fight-or-flight mode they
perceive time to be passing more slowly
which unfortunately will only serve to
heighten their dread of the upcoming
fall but the experience of fear doesn't
come and go with the event that triggers
it in fact fear can stay with you long
after the event itself and in extremely
destructive ways it's been recorded that
8% of people suffer from post-traumatic
stress disorder during their lives and
almost 25% of people will suffer from a
form of anxiety which is in essence a
permanent form of mild fear these events
are processed as traumas and linger
within people's lives causing them
symptoms from anxiety sadness insomnia
and continued experience of terror
sometimes in the form of vivid
flashbacks known as flashbulb memories
it is not uncommon for people who have
suffered a home invasion to become
convinced there is someone in their home
when there isn't or war veterans who
vividly recall a traumatic experience
and all the terror that came with it an
experience which can lead them to live
in a hyper vigilant state on alert for a
fret which is no longer there PTSD
symptoms can last for years and in some
cases can continue to get worse and
worse becoming far more unsettling than
the initial trauma ever was it is
estimated at 11 to 20 percent of
Operation Iraq freedom veterans suffered
from PTSD 12% of Gulf War veterans and
roughly 15 to 30% of Vietnam War
veterans in the general population it is
estimated that five percent suffer from
PTSD at any given time but whilst PTSD
may be one of the worst side effects of
fear are there any positives it turns
out there are studies have shown that
low levels of fear can provoke the right
amount of the stress hormone cortisol to
be released which in the correct doses
can improve your ability to learn and
enhance your memory sounds good right
well before you start revising for an
exam inside a grizzly bear enclosure
it's worth knowing that too much
cortisol can wipe out your ability to
learn and remember entirely so may be
revised just outside that bear enclosure
instead but by far the main benefit of
fear is that it's there to keep you
alive sure it might stop you from eating
the woman of your dreams but it'll also
keep you alive in many ways because
sometimes women can be the death of you
that's what it's designed to do and as
we've learned it does it well so next
time you're scared
be thankful thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video then please consider
supporting me on patreon because it
really helps me to continue to make
these videos you can find a link in a
description also you can get your hands
on a first edition signed copy of my new
book stick a flag in it by heading on
over to unbound publishing via the link
in the description and pre-ordering
yours today thank you